the world of competitive chess was
upended in September when 19 year old
American Grand Master Han Smokey Neiman
was accused of cheating by five-time
world champion Magnus Carlson the
allegations surfaced last month after
Carlson abruptly withdrew from the
sinkfield cup in St Louis after losing a
game against Neiman it must be
embarrassing for the world champion to
lose to me about two weeks later during
a Carlson Neiman rematch Carlson
resigned after making just one move what
no
Carson then explicitly accused Neiman of
cheating saying he hoped the truth in
this matter comes out whatever it may be
the cheating allegations against Neiman
grew louder on October 4th when
chess.com released an investigation it
conducted into Neiman's matches the
report alleged that he cheated more than
100 times in online games as recently as
2020 Neiman denied cheating during the
sinkfield cup or in any in-person chess
match but the Grand Master did admit
he's cheated at two points in his life
once as a 12 year old and in other
random games at age 16. in an absolutely
ridiculous mistake and on radio games
after that I had another one I was 12 I
have never ever in my life cheated in an
over-the-board game in an online
tournament but now with the Integrity of
the game under scrutiny many are asking
how could someone cheat at chess
in the age of smartphones and software
today's cheaters can use computer
programs known as chess engines
chess engines first entered the public
Consciousness in 1997 when the chess
computer known as deep blue beat the
then world champion Gary Kasparov deep
blue's victory was a milestone as it was
the first time a computer beat a world
champion but today these programs are
widely available anyone can download one
on their smartphone they're also
powerful modern chess engines are now
capable of beating even the best human
every single time but if someone wanted
to cheat by using a computer they'd have
to do so without being noticed so how
could the computer get information to
the cheating player unseen one of the
best known methods involves trips to the
bathroom to secretly look at a phone
equipped with a chess engine
since experienced players are able to
memorize the board and input it into
chess software they don't necessarily
need a collaborator to cheat
in 2019 Latvian Grandmaster igorce
Rouses confessed to cheating on four
different occasions in three instances
by using his mobile phone but if a
cheater weren't going to the bathroom
too many times how would they get
instructions and avoid detection
one option would be coordinating with an
accomplice who uses a chess engine and
then sends moves to a device hidden
somewhere on the player's body that
Gadget could be a tiny vibrator or a
nearly invisible earpiece something as
small as a quick Buzz could indicate
that the best tactic is say a night move
rather than a pawn a player could also
receive signals from someone in the
audience
since chess players only need a few
moments of help throughout a game
cheating can be hard to catch during an
in-person game but the website chess.com
has developed sophisticated methods to
uncover unethical gameplay the website
recently closed over 18 000 accounts due
to cheating
chess.com said it was able to identify
matches where Neiman likely cheated in
online games using two main methods
first they looked at Neiman's moves and
compared them to those recommended by
chess engines with analytic software the
website also monitored Neiman to see
what windows he pulled up during the
game when players compete online they
have certain screen and data sharing
protocols they must agree to with
organizers who usually mandate webcams
as well chess.com said it found that
Neiman performed much better while
toggling between screens during games
the second way chess.com said that it
determined Neiman was likely cheating
was by studying his past performances to
get a sense of his strengths and
weaknesses by comparing the moves a
player makes against the moves a
computer would make the chest site
developed a strength score to determine
if a player is playing a better game
than their skill level
Neiman hasn't responded to requests for
comment last month he said he dedicated
himself to in-person chess after he'd
been caught cheating to prove himself as
a player although no one has proven that
Neiman did in fact cheat in his match
against Carlson many chess fans see
chess.com's investigation as damning
Neiman himself has even praised the
website for its analysis they have the
best cheat detection in the world and
due to that analysis chess.com has
barred Neiman from its one million
dollar Global Championship when Neiman
questioned the decision he was told by
chess.com that there always remains
serious concerns about his cheating and
prize events and that there was too much
at stake
[Music]